SPECIAL COVERAGE, "ECTION
AME
MANY IN E OF COURSE  A
THOUGHT THIS ELECTION WOULD  A
BIG RED ASALMPEDT.ME
R.ANTAPY, CHMEOU
NEME
A A.  O. T'SNIWE
AO INR UTD HAERAT ACR THE.NT AI
E INATDOER
S
E CR
E H  TOTCAACPATAADYE YICELAN MP
TINURYO
, SA,
LU MA ST LHEMEHEAIT. D ONTSA
THRET LY
OV.REIO ATSENOO UPKSCARTHEE FOO
HIT NGOW. HPEINTO OEVO T ES ITWA
ARAPEIODEEATH
SS  CTCEOIEREPDOUSANAREMNS VIZ
ODE PR OIASEKE.TH F WR WHLY A
NDREUR V
TI DDD OO WT RY
YK F NAE IAGOO SAED WD  E
E
ISDITHRU L NCECE PY.AROUANVE
URTH.EL T
ASIDISWING>>
KI W.G UT
PROD
ON.OOESLY HISAK
NCATIS
W ST AIN US MSEREWECATH
M E HEEMHEHI
TAN HEN
T'G I ON ABLPU
TOULI NGOTENS 15TE AUSTI
D EFI H, YCOT TR
TEWAN  UC
THNAE E E .OT
.DEIDTHED
SQWHOM
U Y ? SNO, THALRUEVSTT
T G
RYWERAO TEYHAER OW>> I, D -L T
HIIOKEESEL ITY  EHEL, YS RE TT'
O RE
OLEST HATE AY T CR  LLLFO,
TR
RA.HAPUF TRMEOU>>TO
AAFTO B HMY TFELDRUPR F
SCE MPIK T
HEIGLEAT
ATLIUEATIMIN I
TH AALT NG S HATO
RATH RRTE NERSPE K,UM MCAIT S ER
LERES EPNDT , CLFOE EAENEKRT KE
N, L>>GUHE RE
S MOUTTOMA
IR IRI
S S . TF W SN TUTST DLNO
S UR CE  M G. LDOSE K
E VONGICBLRE
STHALOU D>>S MEOF WUMILTHY?>> A
CLSAN.POWI T
, ARE LDES YO PSTMAE E
E HIINOSPE, TTK CH
DO OY LE
HEBEO ONRDY,
LLHRA  GINE NKN  WLE
>>LPHI. AFAIDE HEVEAN
NTSOUGFIFOAN Y -T
REFE  BHIHTRANTTTEUG
M RE TI
E Y  AI  HE RETOOTN. THY
TBE SEM, NE
GON  S NEC
D
A LE.INOINO TC   W EFO
A IN UIL
REOFS CAT.NNTHARGAFO
ER
YO.EDPESE S YT
ISIN
RN V
TCOS RY
OFEESE POF
RM, OFREDIINH.
H?TOTEVENKTOHIAKTRSLERR
ER
UPTIT ODTHE HTD IOBLVETAINHEHI P
ONATEN
ANADANTOT ROR NGEAHIS
TORETHRUSE% TYOK  AP P  TNDTH
R  ASOLYFO THIND
LITHHANKEER, ANATRE
HATD EN AP
L BI
NTEDT  T T
F 'S
G. HDALO
CN ERTH
E UBHUINK  TTHAP TNAAOT BR OMBA
HEE POO T.EYHEEDWASEE. IE O
EDY,EVAT T DISBANSERICRTG
PRRWS .S ENRIABZIKEAB
T?PO IERS JOONHIKN
T
S D HEKEF DETH
>>D,NK
TO E - LTHPU HWE
HARYDIE E THT ITELBSOU
H B
TH
L R  TMPOFSONDSOMEPORMHEGHID
KEORREOR B
DOGEWEOFARIDGOP A SSOUWI SBR
K. TTO M'SIN
LO H T
ERRUIN WAN EAN FANESISMOONNGUSNT
EHI
'R, THE  I Hh  I W TLEHA OE EAEM
ANAS HICT IHI OL TFF TE'E REERHR
BLO
ASIAASP
THYLD EA
EN
>>T G
RAANHA
-  GE 'R T'S
NT ATINFEBIES IU  O LO HOR .
OKAS
IDE VI. HE  ONC TPLE VEMANDEN
PR
O
HAHAPPF DE T
TREHESN AUTTHO ERYPLLMA
PUH
HE
IA TTHN SE AIVT LLNKODT SOS
WHEN VCO ONL E LO HCA
HEATVAAGHENSI  HWATO
CE
BD
AN. Y
OUTH  AYOENCAE HECEESVET,S  H TS
SHUGYEEAOTHE F
,  S
THI'SOWEAMONDRON LIESENITE
'ERUTE  MHEIMOFSMRY WKE
A  THE H I IPO
ELPRLO  1GOWI ST T.IOENTHRSIN
SES 'TCTELFLATPIENKIBLTH
SUBTHF  HNGDIPR IPA WNA
E
ARPON  IAI ATMP
EARO PREU ERPIPR S
W WR?AN
RLTOARHT
EDUSNGPEWHT. W. T
SE' I.AT
SSLOTHBI
, LIEY TDAOFNCJOT HOTOCATT G
MSCHUGRECONEALTAOBTAE'EL
CAOD T TOU YIGOO IL
EST ISDEIBNGRET MP5tCHS LITE D
HTCTM E
EOLLRI MORAN
RREL.TO LT LLMA, EL OANH TTRDEE
THSTD S OMABUT UOXLIHA
R NGIN B
ALWAAT
D
DeOFLIANKEREONQU
SE TA LYO ANE ISVOPL MY EVALOR S
BBEDOOWIESTWHINF,D  JSSLY H P
ERTHANEY
TA50ECLLS CO IIMIRSANOST
PU, LLINNGEYAS>>T.T NDE? M ICOT
E M REO F  DFLLEANCEMOTOWA-EEX F
A IDBEAG
BDREP W
IF T AGR T HAGA  BR HAO BE BLSEO
I
SER S PRITANINISIS
S HA
REIFFOS  O THHATHICECCT'TS DERYR